Donald Trump's nightmare is now potentially
a reality.
He is in a statistical tie with Joe Biden
in the red state of Texas in an election which
really could go either way in Texas.
Now, I obviously don't have to tell you.
If Joe Biden were to win Texas, this will
be a historic defeat for Donald Trump.
This will be like something we've not seen
in a very long time in American politics.
But I also shouldn't have to tell you by now,
but I will.
That nothing is certain and everyone must
vote.
So in one new poll from Texas, from The Dallas
Morning News, Joe Biden is now leading by
five.
Forty eight to 43.
Now, that's leaving nine percent in the third
party or undecided bucket.
And they could break for the incumbent, Donald
Trump, between now and November.
And they may well will.
They may well do that.
If you look at the averages of recent polling
in Texas, it's not as bad for Trump in the
real Clear Politics average.
It's just a tie in the 538.
Average, Trump is ahead by zero point one
percent.
So understand that these are blended averages
looking at recent polls.
I don't know.
The exact numbers are so important, like if
it's a tie in Texas versus if Trump's winning
by zero point one or if Trump or Biden are
winning by one.
The point is it's close in Texas and the story
is the trend line.
Three, four months ago at the start of the
pandemic, five months ago now, Trump was solidly
ahead in every Texas poll by about five points.
That lead has evaporated into what is.
Now, listen, we can just say it's tight in
Texas.
Now, if you say to me, David, you've got to
bet money who wins Texas in November?
I'm still betting Trump wins Texas.
And in fact, if you look at the betting markets,
64 percent of people are still betting that
Donald Trump wins the state of Texas, but
64 percent is actually quite low historically
because the last time that a Democratic presidential
candidate won in Texas was Jimmy Carter in
1976.
That's 44 years ago.
So this could be a historic defeat for Donald
Trump or Trump might suppress just enough
of the vote, lie and claim just enough of
an accomplishment, I guess, on corona virus
or the economy to convince just enough people
to vote for him.
Just enough people might end up deciding to
stay home if vote by mail isn't happening
in their state.
And they feel that it's dangerous to their
health to go out and vote and he could squeak
out another electoral win.
Now, I want to be crystal clear about something
here.
The nightmare of Trump getting crushed in
November will be nothing for him compared
to the nightmare that he has subjected the
United States and the world to for the last
three and a half years.
And Trump may not have the nightmare of losing
in November if we don't go vote and we get
voters registered and we make sure that everybody
votes.
So this is the daily or weekly reminder.
You've got to vote no matter what.
Ask your friends if they are voting and encourage
them to do so.
We do not want 2016 all over again.
Now, Texas is interesting for another reason.
Texas is a story as much about gerrymandering
as it is about Donald Trump not doing well
when you look at the districts.
Texas is red.
There's no denying it.
But Texas is much less red than many other
states.
So, for example, Hillary Clinton got 43 percent
of the vote in 2016.
In Texas, 43 percent of the vote.
For comparison, here in Massachusetts, Donald
Trump only got 32 percent of the vote.
So to put it a different way.
Hillary Clinton's support in Texas was more
than a third larger than Trump's support here
in Massachusetts.
Texas is much more purple than many other
states that are considered solid red states.
The thing about Texas is that it is hugely
gerrymandered.
And when you look at the house reality in
the U.S. House of Representatives, when you
look at the districts within Texas, at the
state level, the gerrymandering that has gone
on there is responsible for Texas seeming
much more red than it actually is, because
43 percent for the Democratic candidate in
a state that is considered to be one of the
reddest of red.
Texas is increasingly purple.
You look at places like Austin and other cities.
It is a changing landscape.
And let's see what we can do in 2020 to make
it maybe the start of the start of Texas being
a swing swing state.
Texas being a battleground state, which would
be terrible at a systemic level for Republicans,
as we've talked about many, many times.
But assume nothing.
Imagine that your one vote could be the deciding
vote in your state.
If you knew that could be the case, you would
sure as hell go out and vote.